Hoy os traemos un nuevo tier list y en este caso vamos a ir posición por posición.
El turno esta vez es los porteros de la primera.
Pues nada amigos, vamos con un nuevo tier list y esta vez vamos a atender las peticiones de las gentes
porque nos debemos al pueblo, nos debemos a nuestros compatriotas del internet.
Y vamos a hacer una tier list para ordenar todos los porteros del actuar en Premier League 24-25.
Es muy fácil, vamos a ordenar 36, todos los titulares y algunos que consideramos que son importantes,
por ejemplo el caso de Trafford que no es titular pero lo tenemos que incluir y los ha ordenado Chozas.
Nadie se muy bien por qué, por el porcentaje de paradas que llevan en esta Premier League.
Porque, bueno, no es un dato que nos guste mucho dar pero Chozas lo ha querido ordenar así y se acabó.
Bueno pues métele Jesús.
Métele a fuego y el primero en porcentajes con un 100% de paradas en la Premier League es Sene Lámenz.
Ahí veis las categorías que la mejor es top mundial, la segunda es gran portero, la tercera es clase media,
la cuarta mal portero y la última es no para un taxi.
Sene Lámenz no le hemos visto lo suficiente casi como para...
Había grandes estadísticas sobre él porque leí que era de las 10 primeras ligas.
El que más paradas había hecho.
Le hemos visto un partido y ese partido estuvo francamente bien.
Pero eso quiere decir que no lo podemos poner en ninguna de las dos últimas.
Pero hombre, tampoco hemos visto más.
Entonces, encuadrándolo en este momento del vídeo, clase media, ¿no?
Pues que sí, sí.
Va a solucionar.
No puedo hacer nada más.
Llevo un partido y ya lleva 0,9 pos-expected goals positivos.
Es decir, ha evitado un gol según lo que nos dice la estadística lanzada.
Es tal la situación en la portería Manchester United que si es un portero que no te quita más de lo que te da,
ya te vale.
Muy bien.
Y te quita más de lo que te da David Raya.
Que bueno, David Raya, insisto, me parece un infravaloradísimo,
sobre todo en España.
¡Arriba!
Y es un top mundial sin ningún tipo de duda.
A estas alturas ya.
Es el mejor portero de la Premier League pasada.
Y mira que es difícil además jugar sin medio cerebro.
Pues mira, lo hace.
Pues lo hace.
A ver.
Es que David Raya además ni siquiera se corresponde su habilidad para los centros laterales y para el juego aéreo
con la altura que tiene.
No es un portero altísimo.
Y no me parece que sea un mal portero por arriba.
De hecho, me parece un mal portero.
Es valiente, sabe proteger bien su espacio aéreo, digamos.
Y luego es de los más ágiles.
Siempre una cosa que decimos mucho David Raya, que me gusta destacar de él,
su velocidad de reacción para levantarse del suelo.
Por eso es un portero que hace tantas buenas segundas paradas.
Porque es rapidísimo y muy ágil.
Y el juego de pies además es extraordinario.
Y de élite.
Bueno, ya es un portero completísimo.
Lo buen parador que es, lo bien que va por arriba y lo buen juego de pies que tiene,
me hace que para mí sea el mejor portero de la Premier League pasada junto con Mads Sells.
Sólo que Mads Sells no es capaz de mantenerlo.
Me ha gustado mucho.
La han preguntado Naís Simón en la selección española.
¿Crees que la llegada de Joan García te va a servir para que te apriete las tuercas?
Y Naís Simón ha respondido, eso también es faltarle el respeto a porteros como Ramiro y David Raya.
Es que David Raya ya podría ser portero de cualquier selección.
Porque es buenísimo.
Y mencionó a Robert Sánchez en ese argumento.
Ahí, con Naís Simón, no estoy tan de acuerdo como veremos a continuación.
Vamos con el siguiente que creo que es...
¡Guglielmo Vicario!
Que a pesar de llevar solo 7 partidos, ya ha evitado 2,2 goles.
Según lo que nos dice la estadística avanzada.
Si me llegas a decir...
Si hacemos este tier listar su primera temporada, dudo en si meterlo en top mundial.
Pero después de cómo fue su temporada pasada, creo que tiene que estar entre clase media y gran portero.
Para mí es un gran portero.
A mí, yo...
Además, me parece que es una estadística...
O sea, una zona hecha para él.
Me parece mejor que la media.
Pero no me parece una estrella mundial.
Sigue teniendo muchos problemas para mí.
En el juego aéreo, en los corners...
Es un portero que no hace justicia a su fútbol.
Al cuerpo que tiene y a lo que podría ser.
Los equipos lo saben, además, y explotan esa debilidad.
Ahora, como parador, me parece que es un portero que le ha dado muchas más cosas buenas que las que le ha quitado al...
Al torna.
De verdad.
Me parece un portero de los que...
Incluso en sus buenas fases de rendimiento te da puntos.
Es que es uno de los mejores paradores de la Premier League.
Solo que está en una liga que le busca muchos rosquillas por arriba.
Quizás si estuviera en otra liga, nos plantearíamos...
Meterlo más arriba.
Pero claro, en la Premier League por arriba sufre mucho.
Y dicho esto, ya que estamos evaluando todo, es un juego de pies a mí tampoco me apasiona.
Pero con todo, me parece un gran portero.
Dean Henderson.
Dino.
Ya ha evitado en 7 partidos 2,5 goles según una estadística avanzada.
Temporada de confirmación la pasada siendo clave con el Crystal Padas para ganar la FA Cup.
Me parece que ya ha dejado la clase media.
Y que Dean Henderson, a pesar de ser más limitador que otros, es un gran portero.
Gran portero.
Nunca va a ser de los mejores del mundo, pero da igual.
Es de los que vamos a ver en este Tier List el que ha encontrado su sitio en el planeta.
Es perfecto el Crystal Padas para él y ya es un héroe de la institución.
Muy buen parador, por cierto.
Muy buen parador.
Como parador me parece un portero muy competente.
Y además su equipo también sabe lo que le puede pedir y lo que no.
Bien protegido, todo se ha hecho por una línea de tres.
Que son veces que a los porteros les ayuda.
Y sin pedirle mucho han ido en juego de pies.
Pero, gran portero.
Pero...
James Trafford.
Solo ha podido jugar tres partidos esta temporada con cuatro goles en contra.
Ha evitado casi dos goles.
Pero también, según la estadística lanzada, le recuerdo una pifia.
No recuerdo contra qué equipo, pero contra el Tottenham, de hecho.
Una pifia bastante grande que acabó en un gol de Joao Pagniens si no me equivoco.
Para mí, aunque creo que tiene un buen futuro, ahora tiene que estar en clase media.
No lo puedo poner al nivel ni de Dean Henderson ni de Guglielmo Vicario.
Aquí hablamos de lo que hemos visto en Premier League.
Lo que hemos visto en Premier League de James Trafford es de mal portero.
Ya veremos en el futuro.
Pero James Trafford en la Premier League ha sido un mal portero.
Ha sido un portero al que le ha pasado por encima la Liga.
Primero en el Burnley y luego también incluso en los partidos en el Manchester City.
Pero a mí me parece que, insisto, acotando a Premier League...
Porque el nivel en Champions League ha sido extraordinario.
Bueno, ya. Pero cuántos de estos porteros que tenemos aquí en Champions League se saldrían.
Para mí es mal portero ahora mismo cuando estamos haciendo esto.
No voy a pedir ni que Jesús desempate.
Lo puedo comprar.
Quiero decir que entiendo que se piense que...
Que en el futuro puede ser un mal portero.
No va a ser un mal portero en el futuro.
Pues puedo coincidir contigo, pero ahora mismo no me parece el rendimiento en Premier que sea bueno.
Yo una cosa importante, lo digo por el que viene, aquí hay que valorarlo en general.
No respecto al nivel de su equipo.
Porque llegamos a Robin Roofs, que le hemos visto 7 partidos.
Ha evitado 2,3 goles según la estadística avanzada.
Está siendo para mí el mejor portero de la Premier League en estos 7 primeros partidos.
Mi duda, por eso lo he dicho antes, es...
Llevado a su nivel en el Sunderland, esto es mundial.
O sea, es de lo mejor que tiene el Sunderland.
Pero no sé si le podemos subir a más de clase media.
A mí me parece que, aunque la muestra sea pequeña, es lo que hay.
Hemos decidido hacerla ahora.
Estamos hablando del portero que quizá más puntos ha ganado para su equipo.
El mejor de la Premier League en estos 7 primeros partidos.
Va de exhibición en exhibición y además con paradas que son algunas, bueno algunas varias de ellas, difíciles de creer.
Es tan exagerado su rendimiento en lo positivo que lo pondría en gran portero.
Pero para mí no está al nivel de Vicari y Henderson.
Es peor portero que ellos dos, por lo que he visto.
Quizá sea un año está al nivel, pero no lo he visto tanto.
Yo es que por lo que he visto es que son 7...
Yo insisto, lo normal sería ponerlo en clase media.
Es tan exagerado su rendimiento en estas primeras jornadas.
Y le ha dado ya tantos puntos al Sunderland que lo pongo en gran portero.
Jesús...
Me encanta cuando Jesús no habla.
Simplemente hace y se ríe.
Compro todo el momento.
Pero entonces, ¿qué más tiene que hacer Robin Roofs?
Demostármelo durante más tiempo.
Hombre, ya, pero entonces es injusto con Roofs.
Es que no... o sea...
Bueno...
¿Qué decir?
Según vuestra razonamiento, entonces, como máximo puede ser clase media.
Ahora, si en estas 7 jornadas ha hecho varias cagadas...
No para un taxi.
¿Eso clase media o baja?
O no para un taxi.
Entonces, lo que hay que hacer es el tierleys más tarde.
No, porque me parece que esto está haciendo un tierleys analizando lo que es ya.
Y yo tengo que tener en cuenta que él está en un Sunderland en el que le tira mucho y en el que él destaca.
Pero porque también es más fácil destaca en un Sunderland que te tiran 20 veces que en el total en el que te tiran 5.
Entonces, ya lo que voy es...
Si Vicarious llega a estar en este Sunderland hubiera hecho más paradas.
Pues quizás a mí...
Que te lo puedo comprar, ¿eh?
Pero me parece que me cuesta verlo al nivel de Vicarious y de Ingenerson.
Solo eso.
Hombre, está en el mismo tierleys.
Pero eso no quiere... o sea, en el mismo tier.
Pero eso no quiere decir que sea tan buen portero como Vicarious o Henderson.
Es a mí lo que me pesa.
O sea, es coincidir en el tier, pero no en la misma altura.
Es que estás al lado de David Raya.
Y entre David Raya y Robin Roeves hay siglos de distancia.
No sé.
A mí... yo estoy contento dejando el cross in media, pero te puedo dar la licencia, ¿eh?
O sea, no me parece una barbaridad.
Me parece que está siendo el mejor portero a Premier League, pero llevamos siete jornadas.
Y matando al Poblis Roeves.
Bueno, ha sido mayoría lo que hay.
Vamos con el siguiente.
Nick Pope.
No para un taxi.
Nick Pope, que carrera más que contrastada en el Newcastle.
Uno de los porteros que mejor va por arriba de toda la Premier League.
Es un juego de pies, evidentemente.
No se le puede pedir mucho.
Pero también es un portero que, aunque lo haga feo, para mucho.
Para mí tiene que estar al nivel de Henderson y Vicarious.
Gran portero.
Vamos.
Pero totalmente...
El portero que siempre ha acabado siendo un seguro para el Newcastle.
Mucha suerte a Aaron Ramsdell quitándole el puesto.
Me parece fenomenal que juegue bien con los pies.
Es un seguro.
Lleva haciéndolo años.
Me da una seguridad.
Tener siempre en el equipo, en la portería a Nick Pope.
Y cuando se lesiona, me entra sudores fríos y el terror más terrorífico.
O sea, en portero, de verdad, la seguridad queda por arriba.
La seguridad queda por arriba, por mucho que el día del Arsenal se le señalara.
Es un portero que transmite una seguridad, su defensa extraordinaria.
Que no se complica lo más mínimo y es consciente de sus defectos y sus virtudes.
Que eso es muy importante en un portero así.
Y es un gran parador.
Las cuerdas, ¿cómo son?
Hay que tener en cuenta lo que dice José Farel.
Se toma en cuenta el FIFA 18.
Si tenemos en cuenta el FIFA 18 es top mundial.
Ya.
Ahí no lo podemos sacar.
Sam Johnston, que ha vuelto a la titularidad de los Wolves por el mal rendimiento de Jose Sah.
Y lo está haciendo mejor que el Portugués.
Aún así, con lo que yo...
Con lo que yo le he visto...
Wolves y Palas, para mí es mal portero.
Es un portero que te quita más de lo que te da.
Mal portero.
Es un portero que me parece inconsistente.
Ya en el Crystal Palace hubo tramos en los que acababa siendo más un problema.
Creo que es un portero muy de paradas espectaculares, de reflejos.
Creo que es un portero muy de highlights.
Pero no me parece un portero seguro.
Y te lo pongo un poco en el caso...
Te lo comparo con Trafford en cuanto a que creo que es un portero que en Championship se saldría.
O tendría mucho brillo.
Para nivel Premier creo que es mal portero.
Y eso que ha tenido alguna que otra etapa buena.
Yo lo pondría en mal portero.
Y ya sabéis que no los ordenamos en tier, así que simplemente mal portero.
Difícil.
Madsels, el hombre que tuvo el arco de redención porque lo fichó en Newcastle en la segunda.
Terminó siendo suplente en Newcastle en la segunda.
Se fue a Francia, estuvo en Estrasburgo.
El Forrest lo fichó.
Nos reímos de su fichaje y acabó siendo el...
Fue cuante de hora al final?
Sí, cuante de oro compartido.
El guante de oro de la Premier League pasada.
Siendo un auténtico seguro y valuarte en los bares tanto por arriba como también cuando había que ir a Chicaragua para Londingham Forest.
Gran portero.
Lo digo por además...
No, no, no.
Ahora, qué poca memoria tenemos.
Gran portero por de dónde viene y que al mismo tiempo haya sido el mejor portero de la pasada temporada.
Entonces, quién me iba a decir que vamos a poner a Madsels aquí.
Increíble.
Fue increíble, Madsels.
Gianluigi Donnarumma.
Solo lleva cuatro partidos en el Manchester City donde ya ha dejado grandes paradas como un Anbeumo.
Como el otro día también a Igor Thiago.
Viene a ser nombrado mejor portero de la UEFA.
No, mejor portero del mundo.
Pone el balón de oro.
Y la Champions que hace.
La Champions escandalosa.
Donnarumma es top mundial.
No, es que el juego de pies es top mundial.
Es un portero absolutamente ganador.
Es un portero de los que, otra vez, insisto, te ganan puntos y te ganan torneos y si no, se lo llegan al PSG y ya le está ganando puntos al Manchester City.
Volvemos a lo mismo.
Esto no tiene nada que ver con la valoración que se hizo de su fichaje.
La valoración de su fichaje se hizo desde mi punto de vista.
No, no, no.
Sí, no lo puse en el más alto de tier.
Lo puse en el siguiente.
Pero yo también, ¿no?
Pero quiere decir que no tiene nada que ver con que él sea top mundial.
Eso está condicionado por el fichaje de Trafford.
Pero él, como jugador, parece que no tiene ninguna duda que es top mundial.
Y, insisto, le pusimos alto, le pusimos un buen fichaje porque él estaba encantado.
Ya sabes que los tierleys siempre se...
Los carga el diablo.
Se te ha tergiversado un poco.
Jordan Pickford es el portero número 11 que tenemos que analizar.
Portero titularísimo con Inglaterra.
Clave para que el Everton se haya mantenido en Premier League muchos de los últimos años.
Tiene sus limitaciones como el juego por alto.
Es un poco histérico a veces en la hora de ordenar su defensa.
Pero para mí es un gran portero.
Vamos, pues ya le gustaría al 80...
Uy, esa pausa, esa pausa me ha dado miedo yo.
¿Usted qué va a decir?
Al 80% de la Premier League le encantaría tener durante tantos años un portero como ha tenido el Everton en Pickford.
Pickford, además, ha acabado siendo incluso una partida de la Premier League.
Por arriba no es académico, pero si usa mucho los puños.
A mí no me gusta dejar muchas segundas jugadas.
Pero eso no quita que también sea un portero valiente.
Que no es un portero que los balones le pasan por encima como si...
Como un portero que no es realmente seguro.
Como parador es extraordinariamente ágil.
De los más rápidos de toda la Premier en cuanto a reflejos.
Le encanta esa parada de balón muy cerca.
Y que es un portero que tiene un buen trato de la parte de arriba.
Y también esa parada de balón muy cercano, balón que hay que ir abajo.
Amocajarlos muy bueno.
Con los pies.
Él tiene muy claro que tiene un buen desplazamiento de balón largo y en corto apenas le hacen jugar.
Yo te digo que gran portero, top mundial, lo que pasa es que para mí te sales de la Premier.
Estás hablando ya a nivel, como dice el tier mundial.
Pero dentro de la Premier me parece de los top.
Porque la trayectoria no admite ya dudas con Pickford.
Ya está fuera de ese debate.
Mons Areola ha jugado esta temporada tres partidos.
Porque empezó de suplente pero ha vuelto a ser titular.
Portero que ha tenido buenos momentos en el West Ham.
Pero que a estas alturas yo creo que no es mal portero pero que es clase media.
Y creo que en algún momento de su carrera ha podido ser un buen portero pero que para clase media.
Estoy cerca de ponerlo en mal portero a estas alturas.
Por las carreras que ha tenido.
Porque ha tenido años que me ha gustado.
Pero vamos ya está para pocos trotes.
Marco Bissot que empezó siendo titular en el Aston Villa.
Leímos dos partidos muy poquito.
Parecía que venía incluso a poder.
Lo hizo bien.
A que se podía plantear que si se iba el D.W. igual no había fuchado otro portero.
No lo hemos visto mucho.
Creo que hay que dejarlo en clase media.
Lo mismo que la men's.
Lo que lo hemos visto está bien.
Petrovic.
Siete partidos ocho goles en contra.
Diezune paradas con el Bournemouth.
Lo fichó el Chelsea.
Lo hizo medianamente bien en el Chelsea.
Se fue al Estrasburgo.
Se salió en el Estrasburgo y el Bournemouth ha confiado en él.
Para ser el sustituto de Kepa.
Yo ahora mismo dudo.
No dudo es clase media.
Es que el nombre gran portero no se le puede poner todavía a Petrovic.
Creo que está por debajo de los que hemos puesto en gran portero.
Pero vamos clase media pero le tenemos que ver esta temporada.
Por ahora bien.
Por ahora no tengo nada que decir especialmente malo sobre Petrovic.
Tampoco me parece la gran razón por la que el Bournemouth está puntuando tan alto.
Pero bueno, sigue siendo una experiencia cortita en premio.
Me cuadraría que termine la temporada en mal portero y en gran portero.
Tenemos que ver.
Dibu Martínez.
Para mí siempre ha sido top mundial.
Pero también hay que atender a los últimos tiempos.
Y los últimos tiempos ha bajado el rendimiento.
Si somos estrictos con la actualidad, para mí entonces tiene que entrar en gran portero.
El gran Dibu Martínez hace varios meses que no lo vemos en la Premier League.
Cuando lo vimos, el mejor portero de la Premier durante ese tramo.
Sin duda.
Y de los mejores del mundo.
23-24 me parece el mejor portero de la Premier League.
Para mí lo dejamos en gran portero.
Para mí también.
No lo puedo bajar más.
Ni de broma.
Berleno.
Me parece curioso que Berleno ha encajado un gol más de lo que dice la estadística avanzada.
En este inicio siempre hemos dicho que fue una de las claves para cambiar el paradigma del fulano.
Que dejase ser un equipo ascensor y que la 22-23 se mantuviera bien.
Buen portero.
Pero creo que no lo podemos dar más.
Es decir, es un gran portero.
No solo lo ha hecho venir a clase media, sino que ha sido estrella en la clase media.
Por eso lo pongo al nivel de un Dean Henderson.
Aparte que venía a hacerlo también en el Arsenal.
Dubravka.
Que pensábamos que se iba a retirar ya.
Que ya no iba a tener más minutos.
Y en el Barley está siendo en muchos partidos el mejor del equipo.
Si quieres estar en la zona media baja, Martín Dubravka es un porterazo y lo sigue siendo.
Probablemente sea junto a Jadon Anthony el mejor jugador del Burnley en este inicio de temporada.
Porque en un equipo de 4 puntos no hay ni un resultado achacable al rendimiento de Dubravka.
Al contrario, en muchos partidos Dubravka ha rendido muy por encima de los méritos de su equipo.
El empate del Forrest es gracias a Martín Dubravka.
Para venir a clase media.
Cuando subes de nivel, cuando ya eres un equipo con aspiraciones europeas, Dubravka se te va a quedar corto.
Pero el Dubravka que mantuvo el Newcastle en Premier y el Dubravka que ahora está jugando en el Burnley,
Demuestra que es un gran portero.
Para ti es gran portero.
Para mí es gran portero.
Para mí es clase media.
Su carrera en la Premier League.
Y ya no solo su carrera, es que luego encima veo su actualidad y es que no puede estar en clase media.
Claro, pero para mí lo hace muy bien en el Barley, que es un equipo de muy abajo, por ser en clase media.
Pero vamos. No sé si me estoy explicando.
Sí, pero esto te lo compraría si no hubiese visto ya lo que fue en el Newcastle.
Pero es que creo que lo del Burnley está confirmando que es un portero que para Premier League, en su nivel, es un gran portero.
Al final es...
Para...
Evidentemente para subir un poco más ya no puedes ser top mundial.
No, no me cagas.
Yo lo que pasa es que creo que tú te preocupas más que yo de que coincidan en un mismo tier, varios porteros.
No, no, no. En este caso no me estoy preocupando de eso.
Va a coincidir Dibu y Dubravka.
No, no, no. Es por eso. Creo que es el portero perfecto para clase media.
Bueno, pues ponle clase media.
Pero vamos, que decía Jesús, eh. Antes hemos desemportado.
Dale, Jesús.
Sin hablar. Siempre tiene la baja.
El hombre silencio.
No, no, no. Es que clase media es buen portero.
O sea, no significa que sea mal portero.
Creo que es un buen portero para la clase media.
Bueno, ni te da ni te quita.
Claro, es eso.
Sí, pero bueno, Dibu y Dubravka muchas veces te dan.
Sí, claro.
Durante buena parte de su carrera de Premier creo que ha dado.
Por eso lo subía un poco más.
Llegamos a uno muy difícil.
Mamardas.
Claro, en el Valencia mucha gente,
creo que más hace dos años que el C último,
hablaba muy bien de él.
Un año increíble, otro año no tan bueno.
Claro, entonces,
con lo que le hemos visto, además solo es un partido
contra el Chelsea, retitular, que sufrió mucho con el juego de pies.
¿Le podemos poner en gran portero?
No, clase media.
Pero siguiendo un poco lo mismo que no lo hemos visto.
Sí, sí.
A ver, no solo eso, basándonos también.
Y que parece que no...
Si hemos visto más fútbol español,
pero si tenemos en cuenta que no venía del mejor de sus rendimientos,
pero que sabemos lo que puede llegar a ser,
porque ya lo hemos visto,
y que lleva poquito en la Premier,
pues no lo podemos poner en gran portero.
Kar Darlau,
que es increíble, pero en un tier list de 2025
tenemos que poner a Darlau,
porque se lesionó perdi en el list y está jugando el 4 partidos.
Ya ha encajado un gol más de lo que dice la estadística avanzada.
Era el portero...
Bueno, era el portero que le quitó la titularidad a Matt Selsen,
el Newcastle en segunda, si no me equivoco.
Están aquí los dos.
Sí, luego sube el Newcastle, nada.
Y hasta que no fichan a Dubravka,
siguen teniendo que tirar con Darlau.
En Newcastle todo el mundo le agradece a Darlau su año en Champions,
que fue, francamente,
es que fue decente.
No fue un porterazo en Champions, fue decente.
Pero no es un portero para la Premier.
No para ni un taxi.
No es un portero de Premier.
El otro día al Tottenham le cuela un gol a Mattistel,
que no te pueden colar, no, ponen un ejemplo.
Pero es que no...
Su nivel está en Champions.
Y en Champions a lo que voy es que...
Pero nunca va a ser el mejor portero de Champions.
Eso es a lo que voy.
No es un traforo.
Estamos haciendo un tier list de Premier.
A ver, es un portero que está porque ha jugado minutos,
pero que es su plante en el list.
Esa es su realidad.
Robert Sánchez, 7 partidos, 7 goles en contra,
ha encajado un gol más con dos,
de lo que dice la estadística avanzada,
además de provocar esa expulsión
contra el Manchester United,
que también es un error que nos recoge esta estadística.
Sabéis que soy muy crítico con Robert Sánchez.
Me parece un portero que está lejos
del nivel del resto del equipo del Chelsea.
Es muy ágil, muy alético.
Puede ser un buen parador.
Su juego de pies me horroriza últimamente.
No me gusta cómo va por arriba.
No da seguridad.
Pero creo que también va a condicionar el nivel de seguridad.
No lo bajo más de clase media.
No es un mal portero.
Yo lo dejaría en clase media
que el nivel del club
ya le ha quedado por encima.
En el Brighton a mí me pareció un muy buen portero.
Sus errores.
Siempre va a ser propenso a cometer errores Robert Sánchez.
Queiming, Kelleher, 7 partidos, 12 goles en contra,
ha encajado dos goles más
de lo que dice la estadística avanzada.
Yo era muy de Kelleher,
pero su inicio me está dejando muy mal.
Me he dejado un buen gole.
Me he dejado muy de Kelleher,
pero su inicio me está dejando...
Tiene paradones como el otro día contra el Chelsea y contra Palmer.
Pero luego también ha tenido errores
como contra él Sanderland.
Me equivoco.
El mismo día del United
el gol de SESCO le tienes que pedir más al portero.
Luego le para un penalti a Broderon.
No es un mal portero.
Para mí es clase media.
Se tiene que quedar ahí.
Porque su carrera en Liverpool me parece francamente buena.
Yo también en el...
Yo también me he dejado de ir a la fiesta de Borussia Dortmund
ante el Newcastle.
Pero tengo muy reciente aquel partido 3-3
que comete un gravísimo error
para que le empate el partido en el último segundo
el Newcastle al Liverpool.
Es un portero que...
Sus mejores momentos son muy destacados,
pero sus errores son muy gordos.
Entonces, lo te voy a dejar ahí.
Barbe Bruggen.
Y lo digo de esta forma porque Barbe Bruggen, tío,
es un portero que llega a sonar para el Barça.
Y no lo digo de...
Se nos preguntó
porque estaba sonando muy fuerte Barbe Bruggen
como posible portero del Barça antes de llegar
el Joan García.
Yo tengo un problema con las rachas de Berbruggen.
Berbruggen me parece un portero de rachas
muy marcadas.
Y es un portero que no me parece excelente en nada.
Pero...
Pero sí
tengo que reconocerle que
cuando atraviesa un buen momento de forma,
sabe prolongarlo hasta ser un portero
ganador de puntos.
Pero luego también es un guardameta que
nunca acaba de verle nada en especial.
Y eso es algo que...
que a mí me...
me suscita bastantes problemas
con él. El problema está que en el...
en el tier ahora mismo
de mal portero no lo puedo poner.
No, para mi clase media.
Creo que yo soy muy duro con Berbruggen porque creo que está un tanto
sobrevalorado. Entonces, me sale
ser más duro con él, pero creo que es un portero
del montón en la Premier League.
No está ni en los 10 peores
ni en los dos mejores.
Este top mundial es de los mejores
porteros que yo he visto...
De los mejores porteros que he visto en toda mi vida.
De los mejores porteros que he visto
en nunca la Premier League. Una leyenda
ya de su club. La única
lástima es que se lesiona demasiado para
ser portero. Pero este tío es
de lo mejor que he visto en mi vida.
Experto en los mano a mano.
El juego de pies también es
fantástico.
Es un pack buenísimo, Alison Becker.
Todo esto de alta y Ballindir.
Todo esto lo estás diciendo.
Alison Becker además está infravalorado.
Pero vamos, la cantidad de veces
que ha sido
de sobra top 5 mundial en su posición
y nunca se ha hablado de él.
No te digo que... A lo mejor nunca ha sido
el mejor portero del mundo. Pero vamos,
este tío ha estado instalado en el top 5
mundial durante años. Para mí, en los últimos
cuatro años, el mejor portero del mundo quitando a Courtois.
Para mí está ahí.
De lo que yo he visto, que evidentemente es más, el Premier League.
Ballindir. Para mí no para
ni un taxi. Voy a ser claro.
Me parece que es un portero
con un juego de pies horrible, que no va bien
por arriba, que comete pifias,
que tampoco me parece un buen parador.
Y su carrera en la Premier League...
O sea, me horroriza. No para ni un taxi.
No es mal portero. No para ni un taxi.
El año pasado le metieron dos goles olímpicos casi seguidos.
Sí. No, bueno, es que no...
Se ha encontrado una situación
en la que en un Manchester United
funcional jamás
habría ocupado la portería, pero
no me parece que este sea el mucho nivel.
Lucas Perry. Tenemos... Bueno,
no para ni un taxi, evidentemente. Lucas Perry
tenemos un problema, ya es que lo hemos visto
poco, un poco como Xene Lámenz.
No ha estado mal lo que hemos visto. No,
pero tampoco ha sido, evidentemente, un Robin Roofs
ni un Dubravka de los porteros. El problema con Perry
es más, de dónde viene. Claro. De dónde viene,
las palabras son muy buenas con Perry.
Portero limpio y el león. Creo que
tenemos que dejar en clase media porque
no... Y encima está lesionado.
Que encima está lesionado. No tenemos ninguna
otra opción. Mads Hermansen.
Joder, macho. Nos encantó
con el Leicester. Madre mía. Nos ha
horrorizado con el West Ham. Madre mía. Y ha
perdido el puesto
con Areola.
Claro, esto, si analizamos,
si analizamos su temporada, no para ni un
taxi. Si analizamos su temporada pasada,
es clase media. Mínimo.
Lo siento. Es un poco incongruente
con que el año pasado os dijéramos que
nos encantaba porque es que había sido un muy buen
parador y muchos resultados no
tenían mucha culpa. Pero, hombre, se ha extendido
con el Leicester. Y es suplente en el
West Ham. Y lo del West Ham ha sido
terrible. Hay que ponerlo en mal
portero. Bueno, hay que...
Esta temporada no para ni un taxi. La anterior, clase
media, mal portero.
Jose Sa.
Una pena. Una pena. Dos años
antes. Dos años antes.
A lo mejor unos cuantos más. Bueno, sí, tres.
Unos cuantos más. Para mí...
A estas alturas, para mí es mal portero.
Lo siento, pero...
Hay que valorar... Antes lo preguntaban en el chat.
Se valora trayectoria o presente? Las dos
cosas. Pero con Jose Sa creo que
el presente tiene que tener un peso
porque es un presente ya demasiado
problema en el tiempo. Hace ya
un tiempo que los Wolves no marcan la diferencia
desde su portería.
En su día me parece un portero.
Impresionante. Muy bueno. Y llegó a tener alguna temporada
de números acojonantes. La
22-23, si no me equivoco, es el portero
que más goles evita según la estadística avanzada.
Pero nada, nada. No me quedo con él.
Philip Jorgensen. Y no, qué decir,
con Jose Sa no siempre...
Hay temporadas que me han parecido malas de
Jose Sa que ha hecho buenos números en esa
estadística, pero...
Ya se me ha quedado corto.
Philip Jorgensen es mal portero.
Lo que le hemos visto en la Premier League con el Chelsea
es mal portero. No ha aprovechado
ninguno de los errores de Robert Sánchez.
Incluso el más grande que fue
en la Expulsión Montal United, él fue el titular
contra él, el equipo de
League One. No me está saliendo ahora.
No me está saliendo. ¿Cuándo?
Esta temporada. Es de la temporada. No me sale.
Lincoln. Bueno, fue un desastre.
Absoluto.
Philip Jorgensen contra un equipo de League One.
No me gusta nada. Está muy lejos
de poder ser titular en Premier League. Es
mal portero. Yo creo que si lo ponemos a mal portero es por la experiencia
en la Liga. Sí, porque si es solo...
Si es solo lo que hemos visto en Inglaterra,
lo bajaríamos más.
¿Qué parrizabalaga?
Para mí,
más que clase media,
porque cuando estuvo en el Bournemouth
fue un muy buen portero
para... O sea, el Bournemouth es el peor
nivel que ha estado,
a nivel de equipo. Pues fue una de las claves
para que el Bournemouth puntuala tan alto.
Ya, pero ahora suplente en el Arsenal.
Pero ¿por qué él lo habrá elegido? Bueno, ya.
O sea, él sería titular en el Bournemouth y
para mí es gran portero.
Te lo compro, ¿eh? A ver,
quiero decir que para mí su temporada
en el Bournemouth me parece fantástica
y que lo necesitaba esa carrera,
pero lamentablemente
tengo también que contar
sus años en el Chelsea perdidos,
el año en el Real Madrid, que también
acaba siendo... Empieza titular y acaba suplente.
...también acaba siendo malo y en el Bournemouth
lo hace bien, pero para
ahora, midiendo el presente, ser el suplente
en el Arsenal. Entonces no puedo ponerlo más
arriba de clase media.
Págame gran portero porque te lo compro.
Te lo compro.
Aaron Ramsdale.
Si te digo que Kepa me parece
una muy buena revención la del Bournemouth.
Eso sí que...
a mi soño me gustó mucho. Aaron
Ramsdale. Lo último que
tenemos de él es otro descenso con Southampton
de la cual él no tiene mucha culpa.
En el Arsenal perdió el puesto con
David Raya porque hay años
luz entre un nivel y otro. El Newcastle
no está siendo titular.
Para mí no es un mal portero, pero es clase media.
A mí me lo deja en clase media
su rendimiento en el Arsenal.
Me pareció muy decente. Muy decente, pero
en el momento que Raya jugó dos
partidos todos dijimos, vale,
el siguiente nivel del Arsenal le pertenece
a Raya, no a Ramsdale.
Clase media.
Dicho esto, es un portero que ha comido descensos
uno tras otro. Ha descendido con el
Sheffield United. Con el Bournemouth y con Southampton.
Pero no me parece mal portero, tío.
No me lo parece.
Fraser Foster. Bueno, a estas
alturas lo hemos metido ya
por lo que ha sido, pero...
No, no, no. Yo lo pondría mal portero.
A mí no me parece
que esté al nivel de
Darlo y Ballindy. O sea, es mejor que eso.
Hay que valorar que tiene 57 años.
200 millones de años, entonces
mal portero. Ya está por la actualidad.
Pero la carrera de Fraser Foster ya le gustaría
a muchos porteros.
Lucas Fabianski, que lo metemos también por lo que
ha sido. Mil años es Salvador del
West Ham. Ahora mismo es el
tercer portero suplente. Mismo situación que
es el poster. Siendo a mí más, me gusta más
el mejor Fabianski que el mejor foster.
Pero los dos a mal portero porque tienen 40
años. ¡Hombre! ¡Mi primo!
El tacones.
Qué espectáculo fue ver a este
tío, macho. Qué poquito duro que estrella
a fugar. Antonin Kinski. ¡Oh!
Qué divertido fue de Kinski, macho. A nivel de disfrute
todo mundial. Todo mundial.
Ponlo al menos un momento.
A ver, es el portero
que ficharon porque querían a Ali
que supiera
jugar con los pies y este tío
es su suicida.
Le hemos visto, no ha jugado,
le hemos visto poco,
pero luego a mí tampoco, para dos me gustó.
No te voy a mentir. Me hizo gracia.
A mí me parece que la Premier está a otro nivel.
Para mí me parece mal portero.
Incluso más abajo.
No, no. ¡Hombre!
Quien es usted?
Quien guillotina, Kinski. No, a ver, pero
¿hay algún equipo de la Premier League del
1 al 20 que se plantearía
a Kinski como portero titular? No.
Sí. Lo digo porque
piensa. Equipos de la Premier League
del 1 al 20 que se plantearían a
Johnston, Trafford,
Hermansen, Sa,
Jorgensen como porteros y
los otros dos. Posteri, le respeto su carreal.
Hombre, a todos dirían ah, bueno,
Kinski ninguno. Es que a tal me... Kinski fue una opción
de ultimísima urgencia porque es que se te había lesionado
hasta el apuntado. Es que Kinski me horrorizó parando.
Así que venga, tengo que... Bueno,
ahora vamos con el Courtois.
Es que Meslieno para un taxi es el tercer
portero del Leeds. Lo metemos por lo
que ha sido, por lo que hemos hablado de él en este canal.
No para un
taxi. A ver,
de las caídas más pronunciadas
que he visto en el fútbol inglés, respeto a un
talento joven. Lo que prometía era
de verdad, pero
para apuntar a lo más alto,
su caída a los infiernos ha sido
terrible. Que te haya quitado el puesto
Caldarlow en segunda división.
En segunda división ya lo hice todo.
Nada, desastroso.
Os lo digo de verdad. Pocas veces
he visto en los últimos años un tío que apuntaba tan alto en Inglaterra
para caer tan bajo. Tiene una entrevista
terrible. Meslieno a dar en algún futuro
en francés hablando con calma
de todo lo que le ha pasado, pero es muy loco
cómo Meslieno estaba
de ser el próximo Courtois a ser
ahora el tercero portero del Leeds.
Vamos con Estefan Ortega, que no ha
jugado esta temporada, pero cuando
ha tenido que ser el suprente de Ederson, lo ha hecho
bien. Un poquito de esa Premier League,
la última en Manchester City, es suya
gracias a la parada de Son. Yo lo que le he visto
no me da para ponerlo gran portero,
pero no me da para bajarlo a clase media.
Tengo la sensación de que si hubiese sido un menos
suplente podría haber sido perfectamente
gran portero. También es verdad
que en el City hay un momento en el que he fichado Naruma
porque lo que
hemos comentado, porque lo decían así desde
Inglaterra, van al Mundial de
Clubes y en el Mundial de Clubes dicen no necesitamos portero.
Salen del Mundial de Clubes con Guardiola diciendo
ostia necesitamos portero. Ni Ederson, ni Estefan.
Como que no ha aprovechado también esa oportunidad,
aunque siempre me ha parecido que cuando ha tenido
que cubrir la baja de Ederson, lo ha hecho con
garantías. Y llegamos a Angus
Gann, que la última vez que hablamos en el canal
fue relacionando a Escocia
y recalcando que nació en Norwich
y que por lo tanto era un traidor a la
patria y que no era escoces.
Así que teniendo en cuenta
esto, Angus Gann evidentemente
no para un taxi. Bueno, pues ahí lo
tenéis amigos.
No creo que haya mucha polémica en
demasiado. Tenemos tres top mundiales.
Leo en el chat
mucho debate con Robert Sánchez,
me lo esperaba ya, sea donde sea que
lo pongas.
No sé si alguno más así que puede tener
mucha polémica. A ver, los tres top mundiales
están claros. Donnarumma, Rayja,
Allison, indudable. Sí, que hemos pillado
en mal momento a Dibu.
Es mi duda. Dibu,
por la consideración en la que lo tengo,
me parece un portero top, pero en la actualidad
ha pegado un bajón.
Luego hay algunos. Pero podrían ser cuatro en vez de tres.
Que no hemos visto como Senne Lames,
que lo tenemos que poner ahí, porque
la muestra es muy pequeñita. Luego Pickford,
insisto, es un caso especial, porque
Pickford acotándolo solo a carrera
premiere, rendimiento premiere, no tendría
problema de ponerlo muy arriba, pero entiendo que no es
el mejor portero del mundo. Va
a haber debate con Robin Rufs,
y lo entiendo, porque
lo he puesto en clase media diciendo
que es el mejor portero de este inicio de Premier League.
Tiene la mala suerte de que hemos empezado con la
posición de porteros, otras posiciones
llegaran en la jornada 20.
Lo tenemos que empezar en algún momento.
Está, porque a nosotros no para un taxi,
los más porteros.
Ahí está. Pues ahí lo tenéis, amigos,
ese tier list de los porteros.
Ahora os esperamos a vosotros
en comentarios para que nos digáis cómo lo ordenaríais,
o cuáles son las posiciones que os bailan más.
¡Vamos, Kiddin!